welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and our guest
is Maurice Samuels the Betty Jane Ann
lien professor of French at Yale
University he specializes in the
literature and culture of 19th century
France and in Jewish Studies his first
book the spectacular past popular
history and the novel in 19th century
France when the Gattis Smith
International Book Prize awarded by the
Macmillan Center today we'll talk with
Professor Samuels about his second book
inventing the Israelite Jewish fiction
in 19th century France which brings to
light an almost totally unknown area of
fiction in France
welcome professor Samuels thank you
let's begin with the book give us an
overview of it well the book is about
the first Jewish fiction in French and
by Jewish fiction I mean fiction by Jews
about Jews and largely for Jews produced
in France starting at around 1830 so
France was you know the first country
that emancipated the Jews that gave Jews
full civil rights and it happened in
France much earlier than in other
countries during the French Revolution
in 1790 and 91 so my theory here is that
fiction offered the first generation of
Jews who had been born French citizens
and who came of age around 1830 that had
offered them a kind of laboratory for
experimenting with the perils but also
the possibilities of their new
historical situation so you know what
did it mean that they were French
citizens did it mean that they had to
give up their Jewish identity totally
did it mean that they had to change it
in some way or did it mean that in order
to stay Jewish they would have to
renounce their French identity so my
theory is that they tried to come to
terms with those dilemmas by inventing
stories about them okay and they're
writing in French they're writing in
French yes it's all in French yeah so
what kind of stories were they writing
what were they writing about well there
were lots of different kinds of stories
and
one big sort of theme was romantic
dilemmas so often you get these stories
and these are very typical of the time
in a way there were lots of kind of
sentimental novels about women who were
falling in love with someone like a kind
of Romeo and Juliet story someone who
their family didn't like these Jewish
writers transposed that story to come to
terms with these Jewish dilemmas so you
would often have a young beautiful
Jewish woman who falls in love with a
handsome Christian nobleman and it
causes her family lots of stress and I
try to argue that this isn't just a kind
of typical romance plot but or you know
well it's not a typical romance plot but
it's also trying to kind of come to
terms with these central problems like
intermarriage so you know the weight of
the past of tradition you know should
they be loyal to Judaism or should they
can they kind of declare their autonomy
or did you find any kind of you know any
kind of controversial kind of writings
yeah well a lot of these writings were
controversial for the Jewish communities
well they were a lot of them tried to
come to terms with really kind of
burning questions at the time everything
from should we maintain all the Sabbath
rules you know in her marriage as I said
was a burning question then as it is now
you know what happens yeah what did what
did happen during that time period were
there intra marriages wow that's a good
question actually historians other than
myself have determined that actually
France had relatively low levels of
intermarriage and conversion compared to
Germany and to other countries partly
because Fran French Jews had much less
to gain from it in a sense because they
were full equal citizens they didn't
have to try to be sure so this is kind
of you know cutting-edge trailblazing in
a way because this is the first time
anyone has really looked at these kinds
of books what led you to pursue this
well part
the historical question so historians
have often given 19th century French
Jews a bad rap they've accused them of
being total assimilators this was the
kind of traditional view that they 19th
century French Jews as soon as they
could become French citizens gladly
abandoned their Jewish identity and
wanted nothing more to do with it and
this was all fine
until the Dreyfus Affair at the end of
the 19th century and then of course
World War two when things went very bad
so I and and this was also we see this
actually in how they've looked at Jewish
literature so I teach a course on Jews
in modern France and I still use this
same textbook that has a chapter on
Jewish literature that says there was no
Jewish literature in France before the
20th century now I knew from my first
book which was on historical
representation in France that this
wasn't totally true so when I was
researching that book I came across a
historical novel called leisure Eve the
Jew s written by this woman named
Eugenie foois from the 1830s and I start
was a little curious about it so I you
know I read it and it was all about a
kind of Jewish woman having this
romantic dilemma was the one who wrote
the book well that's what I didn't know
so I did a little bit of research and I
found out that she was in fact from a
very prominent Jewish family from
Bordeaux and she wrote a bunch of novels
at the time about Jews so when I came
across this chapter saying that there
was no Jewish fiction in French before
1900 I knew it wasn't true and that's
the kind of when that happens it's a
scholar you know you have to keep
researching it so you know when I
decided to write this book I went back
to Eugenie foois tried to figure out did
she write other things were there others
like her so that's really how I came to
okay and how how did you do the research
I mean how many books did you end up
finding yeah well that's you know it was
hard because I knew the detective I
imagined yeah and a lot of time in the
library in Paris and
which is you know not such a terrible
place to have to do your research but so
I knew that she existed and I knew she
had written a bunch of other things but
how did I you know how do you find out
whether there were other people like her
so the first thing I did was a they
published lists of every novel published
in the 19th century and so the library
has those lists I started to go through
them to look for anything kind of Jewish
in the title like a Jewish name or you
know the title like the Jew s yes how
many books were on that list there were
thousands of books yes oh yeah people
were very privileged yes well you know
that the novel was everything in well
theatre too but you know there were a
lot of novels being published so you
know I found some stuff but I had no
idea whether you know and it was really
too hard I couldn't really tell if I was
missing things so the big break came
when um I started to look at the Jewish
newspapers now I knew that they had
published these Jewish newspapers
starting in 1840 there was a kind of
reformed one and then there was an
Orthodox rival the reformed one is from
1840 the Orthodox one 1844 so I knew
about them I kind of looked at them but
I started to look at them really
carefully and I realized that they
published fictions so there was all this
serial fiction all of it met my
definition by Jews about Jews and for
Jews and and even more importantly they
reviewed every novel or even play that
was about Jews and so that really
convinced me that there was something
like a Jewish literary sphere in the mid
19th century that this was much more
than the case of one single author in
fact there was a lot going on how
amazing is that that I read in the
textbook there's this doesn't exist and
then to say wow there's there's and how
many books do you think well I that I
find it's in my book on there were um
you know dozens and dozens of Jewish
writers not all of them wrote about Jews
so I only talked about the ones that
really directly thematized questions of
Jewish identity at the time and so I
have six chapters in the book and I
would say I talked about maybe
eight to ten writers in detail I
mentioned a lot of other ones and each
one of those what I tried to focus on
ones each one represents a different
kind of point on the ideological
spectrum from total assimilation some of
them did want to totally assimilate to
reform like will change the religion to
a kind of version of neo-orthodoxy of
kind of returning to the kind of
tradition and what I'm trying to argue
is that the picture that we get of Jews
is much more complicated than this idea
that they were total assimilators in
fact there were lots of responses so I
was deranged on the spectrum yeah yeah
so how many were was it mostly man
riding or was it women or was it pretty
equal yeah so the first one is I really
determined that usually nifo I had been
the first one you know and in a way so a
woman in a way that's not totally
surprising because at the beginning of
in the 18th century in the beginning of
the 19th century the novel was still
kind of written a lot of times by women
and for a female audience so it's not
surprising that a woman would be the
first one but she's really my kind of my
only woman in fact most of the rest of
them were men interesting and how you
know how astute was the writing
I mean quality wise I'm curious yeah
that's a question that I get a lot are
these writers any good and you know did
I find a Kafka you know a kind of
diamond in the rough that we didn't know
about the answer is pretty much no I
didn't find any you know quote unquote
great writer
in fact these writers are mostly working
according to kind of the generic
conventions of the day so they're
writing kind of you know very typical
novels but um one thing that really
surprised me was that the more I started
to read them the more I started to
appreciate them and to like them and to
even think that they were actually
pretty good so it was a matter of
recovering the kind of questions that
they were answering and once I knew what
those were
I start to realize how actually
inventive they were both you know
ideologically but also literally and I
started to kind of appreciate the way
the small and kind of subtle ways that
they deviated from those generic
conventions started to seem very clever
to me so I don't know if I have been
kind of you know I just read too many of
these novels but I did start to
appreciate them I'm just saying so now
what do you think is gonna happen do you
think you know more and more you know
more and more people will be now aware
that these things exist
my hope is that I can try to you know
get these novels into circulation so you
know are these gonna be put on every PhD
reading list
probably not are they you know but I am
I already edited last year a an
anthology in English of some of the of
my favorite ones where I did
translations of them and I'm next year
that might this book is being translated
into French and to go along with the
publication of it I'm also editing an
anthology in French of of these stories
so I'm hoping that they'll have a life
and there's there's there's starting to
be some signs I was actually asked to be
on a PhD thesis defense in at NYU of
someone who had worked on this after
reading my book so I was kind of excited
about that and I'm feeding them to my
students here too so exactly it's
exciting that these things no one had
basically had them for 150 years and now
well thank you so much for being here
today and sharing some of your work well
thank you it was a pleasure okay for
more information about Professor Samuels
and his research please visit our
website at galley D you slash Macmillan
report be sure to join us again for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale